we work our way down the stands and we
get to the rail i'm thinking myself okay
how is this going to work you know as i
was contemplating this
somebody set off one of them cannons
boom i went right under the thing
i just hold one
[Applause]
oh what a dazzling move by rick we got
to take another look-see the timing the
momentum it was like he was shot out of
that dang cannon oh but look at this don
look at this perfect improvisation and
synchronization i mean you can't teach
that don that is something that is only
learned on the mean streets of the steel
circle you know i wish i could be a
casual fan instead having to work the
field all day right
[Applause]
and i could really
celebrate this win
not a bunch didn't mean it wouldn't
it wasn't blue
and he looked at me and he looked up and
down me but i had unbeknownst to me the
same clothes that the ball boys for the
stairs are sweatpants and a gold shark
oh get a load of this guy
huh
how do we know uh he's a real ball boy i
feel like he just got here maybe he
climbed down from the stands and grabbed
two balls to keep us a souvenir for
himself and his friends
huh
you i'll hold the balls you interrogate
him we'll work together
ah just kidding we're best friends i
turn around they're cotton bomb
everybody's running on the field i get
out their no ball i'm like what
no ball get out where what do you mean
onto the field to get the ball well rick
has made it all to the field he's a man
on a mission what do you think he's
thinking in his thinker right now don
well one get the ball two don't get
arrested but if he's a big boy from the
berg probably in that order well he's
making us all proud look at him go yes
he is you're ready to tackle a a steeler
to get this ball if you needed to tip
that out of his arm got it i know he
couldn't have caught me but you've got a
single focus
where
where is this ball right where's the
football where's the game and that
lasted until i look and i see all the
steelers running underneath the stadium
and i was like i'm just going to follow
them
the ball's out of the picture it's going
out of my mind forget the ball maybe
i'll run into the ball in there right
but right now i'm going with them wait a
minute don wait a frickin minute take a
look at rick he's got some fire in his
eye is he thinking about dropping the
ball oh he's dropping the ball and not
just metaphorically he's got his sights
on something bigger
we did it all
together could go all the way
to the locker room we go underneath the
thing we get all the way to the door
and the media is just like
okay they were all going in the door as
soon as we got to the door with the
media oh the security said oh
we'll let you in let them get settled
we'll let you guys in
and then i'm thinking
uh oh i'm right here he did it he made
it all the way from the stands down to
the tunnel without a ticket is it 1979
or what joe there is no stopping rick
folks
whatever it takes whatever it takes
don't blow this
be part of the media you're a chameleon
you just turn into whatever you need to
be you had to be resilient
whatever it takes
right that's the mantra can you believe
it don rick has done it again he's
blended in with the media now i mean
he's one of us rick is a true master of
disguise well let's see how the stag
plays this one huh don so i'm just
standing there
and i'm like right behind the guy and on
on his camera like these cameras here
but he had you know the walking one he
had the light
with a cord
attached to the top as soon as that door
opened up i grabbed that cord the cord
i'm a core guy rick
now you're a camera
guy yes
yes you're the cord guy as soon as we
get in the door
that was the difference i thought in the
football game who's up on the podium
gary freaking branch
i'm gonna sleep tonight
knowing that i just
my god
it's you
terry freaking bradshaw he shook my hand
i could not believe how big his hand was
but wait a second
when you met terry bradshaw what was
this moment for you it was the best like
when he shook my hand there was like he
engulfed my whole hand my man what you
did today was incredible but you're not
a man
you're a god
you're a golden god with a beautiful
head of hair that i got to tell you
don't be worried it's not going anywhere
i can tell
and i just thought i just shook hands
with the dude that just won the super
bowl i don't have a clue who you are
or how you got in here doesn't matter
today we're champs we definitely got to
get better security
whatever it takes
whatever it takes
that's right terry
[Music]
he was looking at me like you so i
thought time to go
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you